listen to this headline a trumpist with
guns wearing a clown wig was arrested at
Dairy Queen for threatening to kill
Democrats that headline
I don't know that it would have
necessarily been a believable headline
10 years ago or 15 years ago in the
United States but it is now a very real
headline you have to see the story
there's a very good CBS News article
about it police armed man wearing clown
wig said he wanted to kill all Democrats
this is
um unbelievable
uh The Story Goes uh Delmont
Pennsylvania a Westmoreland County man
is facing several charges after police
said he wanted to quote kill all
Democrats this is Jan or maybe it's
pronounced Jan stowovi 61 years old took
a loaded gun into a Delmont Dairy Queen
and police said the quick action of an
officer saved lives this was five days
ago Saturday September 10th when Delmont
police say stowovi walked into a Dairy
Queen on State Route 66 in a yellow
safety vest and rainbow clown wig
callers told police he had a gun within
a minute officer Gregory Stahl was there
multiple people were inside the Dairy
Queen at the time and police say a group
of people including several with
intellectual disabilities were heading
inside officer stuff found stowovi and
took him into custody well great that's
all good but look at some of these
details police found a loaded 40 caliber
handgun and ammo on them
stowovi allegedly told police he was
quote Undercover
and he was quote working to restore
Trump
to president King of the United States
he said he was armed to quote kill
Democrats and liberals
and to protect himself from quote drug
traffickers
when they started to look at stowaway's
Facebook page they found a history of
outbursts and threats in the last two
years the wovey had been asked to leave
two different congregations leading up
to the arrest both congregations sent
him letters saying the you had outbursts
and you were threatening
um
you can sort of Imagine
this person's political views he had
photos on social media showing support
for Trump and a post saying Civil War in
2024
as of the writing of this article
stowovi was not yet in jail but was in
custody awaiting a preliminary arrange
arraignment so there's really two
different stories here and every time we
read about a story like this
you see this mishmash of reactions
thrown at the wall like okay the fact
that this guy was a trumpist this is the
Defenders we'll say the fact that this
guy was a trumpist is irrelevant and a
mere coincidence this is a mentally ill
person this is a mentally ill person
fundamentally and it really has nothing
to do with trumpism there are three
different important reactions to that
first of all it is true that there are
mentally ill people who will eventually
become fixated on something
trumpism is one outlet but were it not
for trumpism at least some of these
folks I agree with you would become
fixated on you know is it a 911
conspiracy is it uh child pedophilia
conspiracy at a pizza place in DC right
we've seen it so some of these folks the
trumpist the trumpest fascination is uh
incidental and it could be about
something else but
it is also true that trumpism is
attracting more of these folks than just
kind of like middle of the road
Democratic Party politics trumpism is
attracting more of these folks than
social progressivism so we can't write
that off yes mental illness sure but
there's something about trumpism here
that is attracting these folks secondly
if you really believe that what's at
issue here is mental illness why isn't
more being done by the very right wing
that claims this is all about merely
mental illness it's not about trumpism
and it's certainly not about guns why
aren't they doing more to prevent
mentally ill folks like this guy from
being able to have guns because the guy
had guns and ammo which as of right now
is believed were purchased legally so
the very people who want to do nothing
about the guns and say this is about
mental illness they aren't doing
anything to get guns out of the hands of
mentally ill people and we know that
there were two churches here who had
sent him off and said you can't be here
you're threatening Etc there should be
some mechanism and it should be a
requirement for the church if they had
acknowledged that this guy owned
Firearms to report to someone here's
someone who's unstable we've kicked them
out for these reasons we believe they
have guns it should be looked at uh also
last thing the the number of stories
related to like fast food and
convenience stores recently Mike pillow
was uh raided by the FBI at a Hardee's
drive through this guy's at a Dairy
Queen I hope that if Trump ever does get
arrested he'll be found at KFC elbow
deep in a bucket of chicken that would
really be the final poetic chapter to
this until entire thing huge numbers of
people report that CBD has a calming
effect that can help with anxiety stress
insomnia and our sponsor feels is a
premium CBD designed to help you feel
your best delivered right to your door
you just place a few drops of feels
under your tongue CBD can also be a safe
method for relieving minor aches and
pains without side effects the thing to
remember about CBD is that finding the
right dose is important and feels even
has experts on call to help you with
that over the phone if you need a dose
of Chill on the go you've got the feels
CBD infused mints and you'll get fresh
breath hard to complain about that and
with a feels monthly membership CBD is
simply a breeze you save money on every
order you can pause or cancel at any
time become a member today and get 50
off your first order with free ship
shipping when you go to feels.com Pacman
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below